we'll be opens with shots of what your
actual children will look like by the
end of this 2.5 hour bonanza of crazy
Peter Pan movie acknowledges the
existence of the Peter Pan play because
art imitating real life imitates art I
shall sew it on for you my little man
genie also elementary school plays you
promised I even brought this baseball to
the play to emphasize this point just in
case your workaholism acted up Poppy's
iPod uncapable promised that signals
there's no way he's making it to his
kids big game cliche these two assholes
reenact the Aaron Burr Alexander
Hamilton duel with dick measuring
cellphones it's so amusing and wasteful
of time gotta fly
well isn't it bad enough your name Peter
banning and between this movie and what
about Bob I nominate this kid for worst
combined movie childhood ever also kid
with crushed dreams only realizes his
dad isn't watching the game at the exact
moment his substitute father points a
camera at it are you telling me this kid
who's all of 12 years old has a goddamn
slider in his repertoire judging by the
swing I'm guessing even if his dad was
there he still would have struck out
also a movie where terrible baseball
kids struck out tries to make me feel
bad because the father wasn't there to
see his sons terrific failure Peter not
only missed the game but he's so late
that absolutely zero people are there
and there was no evidence of a small
game was played or even if a father's
love can be bought super long shot of
Pan Am plane is super long I mean super
long apparently every screenwriter in
Hollywood has been on the plane with
turbulence that somehow only happens to
the people who are afraid of flying jet
draws a picture that shows his dad
falling out without a parachute but
really the joke's on him because he also
drew sharks down below a species
famously unimpressed with how you land
in the water planes flight attendants
let this asshole kid bang his ball
against the ceiling without squashing
that next season them come into six
games I promise absentee father over
promises on next year's absenteeism my
word is my bond what this asshole tries
this again so soon after putting up the
last instance of it Jesus the
screenwriters really really wanted us to
know this dude was the worst father ever
didn't they almost as though they're in
a movie no one decides to close the
front door it's cutting into you
in 20 seconds time goddamn this house
has some powerful mojo and no cliche was
spared when it came to Peters awfulness
as he can't remember anyone's name
somehow 1991 Maggie Smith looks exactly
like modern-day Maggie Smith 1991 makeup
artists were sorceress when it came to
predicting the future fake snowfall on
faking Linda's fake snowfall England I
would granny Wendy have a door that
locks with a villains most
distinguishing feature loud screaming
kids who already hate their father
running pretending to love it while
making tons of noise just so that we can
have another scene showing us what an
asshole business dad this dickhead is
hey men you've got a cell phone
those can talk anywhere thankfully for
the sake of comedy this movie wrote in a
shaggy dog who finds and buries Peters
phone I don't hear you laughing let's go
people
there's a question I've been wondering
about through the first 17 minutes of
this picture and that's whether or not
Jack likes baseball
Jeff does stories so much and he took
all the royalties from children's
intellectual property and laughed all
the way to the bank also since I just
found out JM Barrie based the character
of Peter Pan on his brother who died in
an ice-skating accident before he was 14
this rewrite of history seems a bit
disrespectful keep this window closed I
told you this 100 times did you really a
hundred times I don't open window sure
that means scary man the window stole it
kids have somehow already experienced
characters from Neverland after being at
the house for I'm guessing an hour and
those guys really like stealing
baseballs and leaving for some reason
and granny Wendy the one person who
would believe this doesn't seem the
least bit concerned is it not even eight
o'clock yet why is a kid this age going
to bed before the next episode of
dinosaurs comes on a night gates
my sleeping babes granny knows
everything about Neverland praise to an
earth God to protect her grandchildren
isn't funny that evil Neverland forces
attack granny Wendy's house on the very
first night Peters children are home
alone while visiting their and are
without a decent babysitter unless
you're telling me Captain Hook had
people staking out this real-world house
for the last 30 years every single night
just on the off-chance Peter came back
married with kids roll roll roll huh
damn well you know me if you have magic
that can unlock hatches from the outside
why do you need all the ceremony about
it there's no one noticed the window
just opened a blue snow into the whole
place is that undermined as a guy
closing the window later so what the
hell when the experiences obvious
Neverland people are here on regular
earth feelings but still shrugs them off
to continue her awards banquet instead
of instantly recognizing her
grandchildren were in danger in Nigel
Norman goddamnit give up already Ruby
decided not to show the exciting stuff
while granny Wendy got honored for
things that have yet to make a dramatic
impact casting Phil Collins as the
detective is only going to make me think
solving this case is against all odds
it's not impossible that this whole
thing is some kind of ridiculous prank
the fucking walls are gashed and kids
are missing never hire Phil Collins to
do investigative work thank you look at
us yes now and not owe any time prior to
his kids being kidnapped
arrange for the adoption by my American
parents Hank and Jane Banyan wow that is
some seriously clunky exposition I just
forgot five facts about geography that
line had so much information in it I was
young you know sorry this is John
Williams score which sounds so much like
his Harry Potter score ten years later
and Maggie Smith in the same scene
really reminds me a ton that I've never
watched Downton Abbey oh yeah and the
Harry Potter parallels are too close not
to send in the scene Oh Jeff famously
acted well without explaining the
backstory to him this is actually one of
the grossest creepiest things you could
possibly say
Tinkerbell knew that Peter would be good
and drunk tonight and ready to believe
in fairy tales again just in time for
the plot to kick in too
no one wakes up when Tinkerbell does
this in a house with two recently
missing kids you'd think folks would be
more on edge yep these special effects
look exactly like an actor swinging at
air and being pummeled by air don't
worry Robin we'll fix it in post anytime
someone says I do not believe in fairies
somewhere there's a fairy that falls
down dead oh really dark ripoff of the
bell rings angel wings thing from It's a
Wonderful Life this movie spends a lot
of time on bull like this no wonder it's
two and a half hours Peter doesn't
remember never land so Tinkerbell
straight-up kidnaps him there to force
him to remember because when your
ultimate intentions are good even
kidnapping can be overlooked two hour
and twenty two minute movie about Peter
Pan takes until the 36 minute mark to
even show our bored asses some Neverland
Jesus Spielberg what were you smoking on
this one why didn't she stop him before
he left
Tinkerbell showing more than up strength
to conquer these pirates with her bare
hands decides to go the Home Alone route
while fighting pirates hook hookers
movie gives us the kind of thing you
might expect to precede the title screen
39 minutes into the film which just
feels awkward in a movie called hook it
takes 40 minutes for the title character
to show up and this movie is clearly not
about hook could have waited in the
house until he came back but instead I
kidnapped his children and hope he
remembered how to get back to Neverland
someone here it's not belong stranger
monster loyal I can tell by sniffing aka
reading the screenplay you better get an
attorney and hope to god he's better
than me Peter still has no idea what's
going on which is at this point shocking
to the point of unbelievab ility oh you
yeah yeah the point is Peter doesn't
look like Peter anymore because he's a
dull bastard but still he knows what his
kids look like Oh Peter yes I am
actively rooting for Hook to win this
now fly up there and touch the
outstretched fingers of your frightened
children and I'll set them free if I'm
hooked how does this threaten any way
benefit me if he flies up there I know I
have pan as my adversary I can probably
kill him capture him before he frees the
kids if he doesn't fly how does this
prove anything not flying up to see if
the kids could mean not pan but could
also mean pan but not ready to embrace
it everything about Julia Roberts
playing Tinkerbell in this movie screams
I did this between takes while filming
dying young and sleeping with the enemy
dumb pirates ex machina thank goodness
for Peter and every land is like Skyfall
and there are happy mermaids all over
the place to help him not die from a
certain drowning normal people would die
from part of Peters learning how to save
the day involves him kissed cheating on
his wife with
multiple underwater mermaids because
that's how moral men behave of course
also slutty scuba mermaids actually and
that's not a cent I just wanted to say
slutty scuba mermaids how did the
mermaids know to put Peter in a seashell
that would take him up to this island
where Tinkerbell is somehow sleeping
this movie like The Wizard of Oz where
everything that happens is real because
it's your imagination which means it's
not really real but it is but it isn't
also the hell is Tinkerbell sleeping for
wasn't she just on the hook ship a
minute ago Wow okay what the hell porn
you're just gonna leave Kiefer
Sutherland at the altar for Jason Patric
again that wait I'm massively confused
man this movie is way more Newsies than
I think it wanted to be asshole just
said he believed everything a minute ago
it's now back to his dick self again
because dicks meanwhile his Tinkerbell
so she can tell all these kids that this
is Peter Pan even if he doesn't act like
Peter Pan did she go take a nap again
cheek ball shot for laughs you could
have told the entire crew a minute ago
and spared us this non-lethal boring
adventure scene but now you're wasting
time with these two Rando kids while
Peter is out in the open being attacked
by the rest of the kids
Peter's Peter gets aggressively sniffed
by a flower this is a clear halfpipe
that is also pretty clearly contained
and easily escapable yet Peter won't run
back and forth on it for several moments
to create some kind of tension what when
did he get on a skateboard he climbed
out of the natural halfpipe and screamed
helmet a few seconds ago but we never
saw him encounter and climb aboard a
damn skateboard actually no the special
effects are doing that job is this the
official Peter Pan tester how do you get
that job oh you are Peter oh good can we
start the movie now not to kill Patton
when I had the chance good question just
because you lament your mistake doesn't
make it right hook and Smee have a gene
Hackman Superman map of the terrain but
somehow still haven't explored at all or
found the Lost Boys
it's a scene like this that makes you
wonder if you can even say it's all in
Peters head because why would he be
imagining the conversation between Hook
and Smee in the captains quarters that's
racist we can make the little buggers
laugh yeah the plot of this movie is now
Captain Hook tries to make Peters kids
love him to get revenge and real life
the stupid idea would get rejected by
any respectable bad guy but it was not
rejected in Hollywood Smee uses his own
earwax to tighten up hooks mustache and
I've just thrown up on my keyboard and
one of my cats
pan training also doesn't this kill the
whole idea if you can fly if you just
believe or if you have great imagination
or something like that you need to
exercise
granny windy is probably rolling in her
grave
I think the jury is still out on the
effectiveness of jumping jacks as an
exercise but regardless a fakes turning
blue is not a sign of workout progress
but rather of a man whose air supply has
been cut off boss boys continue to
encourage poor health how does this help
me get my kids back it doesn't shut up
lost boys who all understand flying is
related to happy thoughts and not
physical propulsion still somehow
inexplicably created this giant
slingshot flight trainer that will in no
way train a person to fly since it has
no happy thoughts elements to its design
ah seriously
Tinkerbell feels just as forced and fake
as when Ed Wood got his wife
chiropractor to finish the Bela Lugosi
scenes when plan 9 from outer space kids
care about made upgrades provided by the
evil ship captain that kidnapped them
because the plot told them to what did
he go to your baseball game how the
ever-loving do you know that is this
just the movies way of saying hook is
evil Peter Som how terrible line of
dialogue serves only to set up future
terrible wordplay base character
development even though all the Lost Boy
training we saw earlier had every lost
boy serving as a spectator slash
Humiliator apparently lost boy training
eventually gets to a place when the
landscape is on fire and the subject is
entirely alone in void of lost boy
mockery our town banquet side character
twins do everything in unison cliche yes
the movie did just try to earn a laugh
through bodily gas expulsion this is a
Spielberg joint y'all you got to expect
the classy Rufio and Peter Whannell
exchange PG friendly cut downs for two
minutes
motherlover nearsighted gynecologist to
accept those substitute chemistry
teacher these kids are suddenly swayed
by an insult referencing an
institutional profession they can't
possibly comprehend or even ever heard
of dude trying to start the chant that
is your own name don't be that guy man
[Applause]
that's great but weren't you so
bewildered by the invisible food earlier
that you can't possibly have put any
invisible food in your bowl here uh-huh
got you moving Peter so are these kids
actually dead skeletons imagining good
health Peter's imagination of a meal
includes a huge tray of animal legs
somehow all facing outward like a
pincushion several bowls of whipped
colors and a container of mostly boring
vegetables hmm welcome to flavor country
none of this is happening you would have
you believe that this Anselm would throw
a coconut at someone everyone else here
loves and that someone would see it warm
Peter and that Peter would have enough
time to spin in a complete circle and
then cut the coconut into and wait Rufio
threw a coconut that's more simple than
any of the previous three sentences I
just said did he clean these clothes
after the imaginary Foofa okay so it
makes for a nice shot Peter looking down
over the harbor where his singing
prisoner daughter is but with geography
this tight it's amazing Captain Hook
hasn't found and killed every single
lost boy in the cove 20 full seconds of
lantern blowing out I'm asleep
Neverland has three moons which is
probably hell on the gravity around this
place father hating represented as clock
smashing because duh naturally don't you
see the connection you dickface hell I
ever made of promise Jack I have well no
I guess but have you ever even made a
promise at all luckily there's an
appointed time by which hook takes his
hook out for no reason Peter actually
has hooks hook in his grasp but let's go
because of the ex machina timing of his
son's at-bat in the ball pirate baseball
game Smee commits 5 bucks in this
warm-up that admit this is some goddamn
baseball being played here any kind of
inspirational moment this kid gets from
being a hero will be a total eye hook
scold the Pirates for shooting the
baserunner and not playing the game by
master Jack's rules but then does not
also restock the bases with a pinch
runner as should be allowed by the rules
if a player and base outright dies of
course the Pirates mess up home run and
somehow jack takes it as a message that
his twelve-year-old mind probably
shouldn't even comprehend I mean right
x2 it is something about pussy and come
give us a peek but that doesn't cycle
through his prepubescent mind at all so
the guy who didn't even know what
baseball was a minute ago somehow
developed a curve ball you it's probably
due to the three moons besides hitting a
home run in this park is for assholes
gotta tell ya whatever it is in this
world that helps you out when you're at
your lowest sure takes at sweet-ass time
or at least until the plant needs to
move forward Jack my dress
[Music]
sexualizing the relationship between
Peter and tink was one of the worst
ideas this movie had
I mean its dick as as tall as she is but
were they thinking it's great that Peter
is remembering all this stuff now but
why didn't Tinkerbell or somebody bring
him down here a lot sooner was he not
ready or some member my mother not at
that age you don't terrible mother is
goddamn awful at mothering also when the
baby was found Tinkerbell basically said
hey free baby and took him off to
Neverland and set it back to his mom I
ran away you did not run away your
carriage drifted down a slope and you're
a goddamn baby crying in the rain but
whatever remember this however you need
to in order to get your happy thought on
so we can end this bitch okay Steven
Spielberg would go on to do this very
same scene and catch me if you can
eleven years later
wholly discount future ex-girlfriend of
Ben Affleck and Brad Pitt I've seen
young Wendy's boobs in another movie and
now I feel uncomfortable rainy windy
allows this to happen to her sleeping
granddaughter Peter suddenly decides
right after hearing Wendi is old to
settle down and fall in love which is
only slightly less shocking than the
fact that Tinkerbell shows up right at
that moment to witness the dude she
loves kiss someone else I can see why
you have trouble finding a happy thought
so many sad memories Peter including
kissing your future wife
terrible Peters flying alone along with
the film soundtrack somehow I learned
all the Lost Boys that they should stop
what they're doing and look to the sky
immediately I'm glad the movie's main
villain finally got his comeuppance oh
wait this is a way unnecessary dick move
by Peter here you're the pan everyone
loves you do you still need to dick over
Rufio right now it's amazing how much of
a dick you have to be in order to be pan
seeing Tinker Bell's apartment which
appears to be things from Peter
paintings pocket makes me wonder what
the fuck is going on kids
oh Jesus and remembering his Peter Pan
as he forgot his kids what happened yeah
she actually had to be in the movie for
once you're humongous 2.5 hour movie has
time for enlarge very warped Cinderella
Bowl third party romance storyline Jack
those people I literally couldn't
remember less than two minutes ago I
love them never come back yes Jesus he
just told you he loved his earth family
and not you are you still clinging to
this never existed romance one confused
baseball game and then BAM Jack is in
love with being Hook's protege by the
way if this is actually all happening in
Peters mind because he was drinking this
is the strongest alcohol ever created no
what's up and now for some of the most
bloodless sword-fighting ever put to
film don't I know
what if Neverland is going to fog up
everyone's memory of everyone else least
you could do was explain that even one
time in a two-and-a-half-hour movie
bunch of food fighters somehow defeat a
group of armed pirates this is one of
the only movies in history whose target
demographic gets younger with every
minute of runtime you know this is the
second time that fat kid has been used
as a projectile in this battle and I
just have to say isn't the actor a
little too young to know what he's
signing up for this is character called
that kid joke's on her or was he and his
entire family duped into becoming this
movie's fat joke this movie is doing
everything it can for me to hate it the
Lost Boys think food coloring plus
squirt gun equals valuable battlefield
weapon and thankfully for their sake the
movie agrees oh yeah I forgot I had a
daughter damn wait if Peters son can't
recognize his own father because he's
changed then why can his daughter
recognize him choreographed chaos of
nothingness once again if this is all
playing in Peters head right now what an
egotistical bastard this guy became in
his own dream surprised he isn't Bank
Julia Roberts while he was at it while
his wife looked on and encouraged it and
the Avenger
oh Jesus not another adventure we
already got way too many Peter had to
work really hard to remember how to
imagine fake food and how to find a
flight worthy happy thought but
sword-fighting
that's like riding a bike obviously
movie that spent 80% of its runtime on
really boring emotional bullshit spends
the final 20% on an even bull your sword
fight
the events of this finale are to be
believed the plank Peter just tapped
should be flying into hooks balls right
now
these kids wasted all their money on
clocks when they have no food movie says
people without mommies are by rule
terrible people I want you to take your
ship and go will you wake up already
does your mind actually have to banish
Captain Hook before your own hook-like
tendencies go away in the real world
hook not stabbing Peter here is a
goddamn sin against logic what happened
at the clock attacked Steven Spielberg
would shoot this exact scene two years
later in Jurassic Park
no I guess all that kidnapping really
did go down then did we just watch a
movie really goes too far with The
Wizard of Oz parallel one of the kids
float into the bedroom but Peter ended
up in the snowy street Peter's human
wife Maura doesn't really seem remotely
weirded out by the crazy cousin
literally floating off into the night
sky
good block
[Music]
for
captain George hid this uncomfortable
hunk of metal up my ass two years
hello chosen trouble looks like we'll
have to send someone down what is this a
center for ants
and then you'll die
[Laughter]
[Music]
and I know that if you could stand now
you would express much better than I
have captain my captain feelings of sit
down mr. Anderson gratitude to my
captain
appreciation mr. Lestrade I wanna check
out the warm feelings
[Music]
Thank You boys